[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'Afrique dont certains ont dit qu'elle
disait pas rentrer dans l'histoire va
finalement elle a toujours été un enjeu
géostratégique non
absolument on l'a vu à l'époque de la
colonisation donc au 19e siècle avec ce
fameux Scramble Africa partage de la
scandale c'est notamment le Congrès de
Berlin en 1885 exactement qui a présidé
au partage du continent entre les
grandes puissances européennes
principalement l'Angleterre et la France
et l'Allemagne dans une moindre mesure
enfin une part du gâteau beaucoup moins
importantes on l'a vu également dans le
courant du 20e siècle avec le par la par
prise par les Africains dans les deux
guerres mondiales et enfin on l'a vu
durant la guerre froide ou la frottement
pipolaire c'est également jouer sur le
continent sous influence russe
synthétique et des pays sous influence
occidentales et notamment américaine et
française
même si comme aujourd'hui à mon avis le
choix des camps différents n'étaient pas
aussi tranchées qu'on voulait bien le
dire la force diplomatique des États
africains a souvent été de jouer sur les
concurrents internationales et de se
positionner soit dans un camp soit dans
l'autre mais également dans le cadre du
mouvement des Non Alignés alors
justement à la faveur du conflit en
Ukraine avec l'invasion de l'Ukraine par
la Russie il y a eu des votes il y a eu
deux votes principalement aux Nations
Unies et Stupeur et tremblements il y a
beaucoup d'États africains notamment à
l'occasion du premier vote qui a eu en
mars qui soit n'ont pas condamné
l'invasion soit ce sont abstenus
certains pays ça a été très étonnant
comme le Sénégal la première fois ou le
Congo Brazzaville les deux fois qui a
refusé de condamner donc ça veut dire
que là aujourd'hui c'est quand même
encore
une façon de dire ben nous on veut pas
rentrer dans ce conflit on ne veut pas
être aligné c'est ça ça veut dire ça
absolument il me c'est pas notre affaire
ce n'est pas notre affaire mais aussi il
faut tenir compte de l'histoire de
chacun des pays vis-à-vis de chacun des
deux crans si on prend un pays comme
l'Afrique du Sud sa position s'explique
par le fait ne condamne pas condamner
non plus par le fait que la lutte
anti-aparté a toujours été soutenu par
l'Union soviétique à l'époque dans le
cas du Sénégal
Macky Sall était à l'époque président de
l'Union africaine et étant donné
l'absence d'unité de position de tous
les membres de l'organisation à refusé
de se positionner donc au-delà de cette
absence
de soutien à un camp ou à l'autre je
pense qu'il est très important de
rentrer aussi dans le détail des
positions de chacun on est aussi dans
l'esprit de la conférence de Bandung ou
si différent la conférence de Bandung
c'est une grande conférence qui a eu
lieu en 1955 en Indonésie dans laquelle
certains grandes figure de l'histoire
ont marqué de leur empreinte c'est nez
rouge
et c'est beaucoup d'autres présidents on
est dans cet esprit là alors à mon avis
on est dans quelque chose de différent
on est dans une période où les États
africains ont décidé de multiplier leur
partenaire au-delà des relations que
ceci peuvent entretenir entre eux c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des
diplomaties africaines revendiquent
d'affirmer avant tout leurs intérêts
propres et non pas de s'aligner sur des
problématiques qui ne les concernent pas
directement aujourd'hui il y a une
grande ouverture une grande compétition
bien entendu entre un blog qu'on peut
qualifier d'anti-occidentales et un bloc
occidental mais également à l'intérieur
de chacun de ces blocs on aurait tort à
mon avis de ne pas se rendre compte
qu'aujourd'hui certains pays européens
par exemple
se présente aussi comme des offres
alternatives à celle qui a été celle des
partenaires traditionnels donc je pense
qu'on est dans quelque chose d'assez
nouveau où les États africains oui
affirment leur souveraineté et leur
priorité accordée à leur propre intérêts
est-ce que dans cette volonté de
non-alignement vous ressentez un
sentiment antioxydantal qui est en train
de se développer
à l'évidence oui c'est extrêmement
frappant on parle bien entendu beaucoup
du rejet dont fait l'objet la France et
vous avez tout à fait raison de
l'inscrire dans un cadre plus large qui
va
au-delà du rejet des États
occidentaux qui touchent également les
acteurs non négatifs aujourd'hui il y a
un discours assez violent de rejet par
exemple des organisations non
gouvernementales
occidentale absolument auquel on
reproche des ONG auxquels on reproche de
monopoliser les financements au
détriment des ONG national et locales
auxquelles on reproche de promouvoir des
normes et des standards et des principes
qui vont à l'encontre de la culture du
continent ce rejet touche également le
système multilatéral dans son ensemble
notamment
le système onusien au nom des normes et
des standards qui sont présentés comme
étant souvent appliqués de manière
partiale au continent africains vous
voulez dire qu'il y a une espèce de
développement de d'une africanité c'est
ça c'est quoi c'est un africanisme
particulier non alors
c'est tout de distinguer les deux
africanités et panafricanisme parce
qu'en effet il y a cette revendication
d'une africanité et de la mise en avant
des spécificités du continent et de son
contexte
d'un autre côté il y a effectivement ce
mouvement qu'on peut qualifier de Néo
panafricaniste qui
promeut une vision extrêmement
patriotique voire nationaliste et de
rejet virulent je pense que ceux qui
revendiquent leur africanité ne se situe
pas nécessairement dans une
confrontation avec le monde
occidental à l'inverse de ceux qui
aujourd'hui se revendiquent du
panafricanisme
absolument et dont la vision est en
réalité assez éloignée de celle des
pères
du panafricanisme originel d'accord
est-ce que alors il y a une chose qui
polarise pas mal d'attention notamment
en France aujourd'hui c'est ce qui se
passe au Sahel dans la bande sahénienne
avec cette cette arrivée bien des Russes
et notamment de la milice Wagner
entretenu par un homme qui s'appelle
Prigogine qui est un homme qui est assez
proche du Vladimir Poutine et un
sentiment anti-français alors là qui est
très très violent ce sentiment
anti-français est-ce qu'il est dû
seulement au fait que les militaires
français sont accusés de ne pas avoir
éradiqué d'une certaine façon le
djihadisme je pense que ce sentiment à
de multiples causes bien entendu
l'incapacité qui a été celle de
l'opération barkhane mais finalement de
tous les acteurs internationaux présents
à juguler la poussée du terrorisme et de
ces groupes djihadistes et la première
explication mais il y a également la
façon dont l'analyse du conflit c'est
heurté une vision stratégique locale
complètement divergente on a beaucoup
mis l'accent sur justement cette lutte
cette volonté d'éradiquer les groupes
terroristes alors que si l'on prend les
autorités maliennes ce qui les préoccupé
beaucoup c'était la tentative de
sécession des groupes touareg au nord
qui se sont alliés avec les français ce
qui a véritablement été perçu comme une
trahison il y a certaines confit de
territoire en fait des conflits de
territoire et des conflits
communautaires également il y a eu aussi
des attitudes qui ont été perçues comme
absolument insupportables et du
arrogance qui est désormais rejeté qui
explique aussi ce rejet la convocation
de peau dont on parle souvent par
Emmanuel Macron
de convocation dans la ville de Pau dans
la ville de Pau
deux chefs d'État africains c'était il y
a deux trois ans exactement et
pour leur dire un peu leur carte vérité
c'est
qu'ils avaient des armées qui étaient
peut-être d'armée qui était pas très
absolument et qui a été perçu comme
particulièrement irrespectueuse y
compris par les opinions publiques
contestait ces chefs d'État il y a
également le deux poids de mesure dans
la politique française que l'on reproche
aujourd'hui et dont l'incarnation et la
position vis-à-vis du Tchad dont le
président actuel a encore été reçu à
l'Élysée et lorsque l'on voit les
réactions en Afrique c'est une
incompréhension alors parfois forcer
instrumentalisé mais très souvent
sincère en disant mais pourquoi alors
que on est face à un régime
inconstitutionnel composé de militaires
et qui plus est dirigés par le fils d'un
président décédé dans le cadre d'une
transition dynastique on condamne les
gens le fils de en l'occurrence on
constate les jantes au Mali dans une
moindre mesure au Burkina Faso en Guinée
mais pas au Tchad et ça ça fait aussi
partie des incompréhensions en tout cas
des reproches qui sont formulés par les
opinions publiques à l'encontre de la
France alors le prétexte invoqué qui
n'est pas un prétexte d'ailleurs qui est
une raison invoquée à Paris enfin qui
est pas invoqué d'ailleurs qu'un peu
mise de côté c'est de dire que l'armée
de tchadienne est très présente dans la
lutte contre le djihadisme là où l'armée
burkinabé et l'armée malienne sont
beaucoup plus faibles et beaucoup moins
importante dans le dispositif de barkham
alors à titre personnel je récuse
totalement cette analyse l'armée
tchadienne est extrêmement impliquée
dans la lutte contre la secte islamiste
boko-arabe du côté du bassin du lacchade
mais en Afrique oui centrale donc de
l'autre côté de du Sahel mais en dehors
de l'intervention
en 2013 aux côtés de la force Serval où
en effet les Tchadiens en jouant un rôle
absolument majeur le Tchad a toujours
négocier de manière extrêmement ardues
ça participation à la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans le sel central et sa
principale illustration on la matière a
été son déploiement dans l'ouest du
Niger où il y a eu des accusations
extrêmement graves de viol contre ces
contre ces soldats donc attention à ce
qu'on définit comme une armée une armée
de guerriers n'est pas une armée
professionnelle de soldats
nécessairement alors vous qui êtes
d'origine malienne c'est important
comme vous voyez vous l'arrivée des
Russes comme ça là en plus de façon
non-officielle c'est pas Moscou c'est
pas la diplomatie de Moscou c'est une
milice certes très proche du régime mais
qui s'installe
Centrafrique Mali
peut-être Burkina Faso peut-être
ailleurs en tous les cas qui fait des
qui tissent des réseaux d'influence pas
uniquement d'ailleurs en Afrique
francophone comme vous vous sentez ça
alors moi je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
justement dissocier la société militaire
privée Wagner j'insiste sur ce terme
parce que l'une des difficultés à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés et le
statut juridique extrêmement flou de
cette organisation qui n'est pas
uniquement
investi sur le terrain militaire et qui
investit dans le domaine médiatique qui
investit dans le domaine minier etc donc
il y a mon avis difficile de la
qualifier uniquement comme un groupe
mercenaire ou milicien et qui plus et
qui a des liens
difficiles à démontrer mais absolument
avéré avec la russe des Affaires
étrangères c'est-à-dire il abroche en
Afrique exactement et on voit très bien
il y a encore cette visite qui vient de
se dérouler du ministre
au Mali en Mauritanie il faut pas
l'oublier également ou a été réaffirmé
la force de la relation bilatérale on
est vraiment dans un partenariat
bilatéral affiché affirmé où l'on ne
reconnaît pas forcément le type
d'acteurs qui sont sur le terrain
d'ailleurs Vladimir Poutine et sergueil
lavrosse ont reconnu que le groupe privé
Wagner était présent au Mali ce que déni
totalement les autorités locales mais
au-delà de ça ce qui est important de
voir c'est que la Russie aujourd'hui
réactive en tout cas au Mali et dans une
noix de mesures au Burkina Faso des
réseaux extrêmement anciens dont elle
disposait dans les années 60 jusqu'à la
chute de l'Union soviétique la
coopération militaire est de défense a
été extrêmement poussée extrêmement
étroites il a eu de très nombreuses
échanges notamment d'envoi de militaires
ou de civils également en Union
soviétique ou dans les autres
républiques notamment à l'université de
lubumba exactement et il y a encore
aujourd'hui un grand nombre de locuteurs
russophone au Mali donc il y a cette
réactivation de réseau de l'époque qui
plus est avec cette rhétorique
anti-impérialiste qui était également
présente du temps de la guerre froide
mais exactement mais évidemment avec des
techniques
d'aujourd'hui notamment via les réseaux
sociaux mais pas uniquement on parle
beaucoup de ça le rapport à la presse
locale est extrêmement développée
loyauté d'une certaine façon par Moscou
elle n'est pas noyauté en tout cas au
sel on ne peut pas dire ça en
Centrafrique certains médias le son mais
en tout cas elle est pénétrée par ses
réseaux russes alors maintenant il y a
vous savez il y avait les sommets France
Afrique qui n'ont pas tout à fait
disparu mais qui ont changé de forme et
là maintenant on a des sommets Russie
Afrique
le premier Sommet a eu lieu à Sotchi
donc est une ville qui est chère à
Vladimir Poutine en 2019 il y a un
sommet qui va se dérouler en juillet
prochain et normalement c'est un
rendez-vous annuel qui organisé la
Russie ça veut dire que à la place de la
France Afrique on va avoir bientôt la
rue Afrique ce qu'il faut oui avoir
parlé de la Chine Afrique alors il y a
c'est exactement ce que j'allais
mentionné il y a des sommets France
Afrique il y a des sommets Russie
Afrique il y a des sommets chinesafrique
il y a des sommets indafrique il y a des
sommets Turquie Afrique il y a des
sommets européens africains il y a eu un
sommet très récemment États-Unis Afrique
donc je pense que ce que l'on a mal
mesuré en réalité au cours des dix
années qui se sont écoulées c'est que le
continent africain a intéressé un nombre
croissant d'acteurs non
occidentaux ou non européen puisqu'on a
longtemps considéré que c'était
voilà que c'était une chaise gardée mais
des relations notamment d'un point de
vue économique ce sont développés avec
d'autres partenaires et on découvre
aujourd'hui que l'Afrique est très
investie dans une diplomatie non
occidentale en réalité c'est ce qui fait
dire que l'Afrique était le continent du
21e siècle ou le conducteur de l'avenir
là où on vient chercher des richesses
alors ça je n'en suis pas convaincu je
pense que la plupart des continents ont
de très grandes potentialité au-delà de
la seule Europe et des seuls États-Unis
ce qui est certain c'est que l'Afrique
aujourd'hui pèsera plus économiquement
que ce qui a été le cas jusqu'ici mais
elle a quand même un grand nombre de
handicaps notamment en matière de
sécurité il y a quand même une
insécurité qui se diffuse sur le
continent et qui est particulièrement
préoccupé par exemple des villes où on
japonais assez facilement comme Abidjan
alors encore pire un aérobie des villes
comme ça maintenant c'est des villes où
un peu à l'image de ce qui se passe en
Afrique du Sud c'est compliqué de
circuler si vous n'êtes pas barricadé
quoi et protégé alors côté kenyan ça
très certainement il y a une sorte de
mouvement de type ville américaine
quelque part avec une privatisation
notamment de la sécurité
privée
des individus dans l'Afrique
occidentale de l'Ouest en tout cas et
centrale à mon avion n'en est pas encore
là même si il y a de nombreuses
compagnies de sécurité c'est plutôt une
criminalité
moins importante que l'on constate dans
ces villes mais qui en effet
rend beaucoup plus difficile qu'à une
certaine époque le fait de se déplacer
librement alors on dit c'est le
continent certains ceux qui disent c'est
le continent de l'avenir c'est le
continent du 21e siècle c'est un
continent qui est truffé de richesse et
c'est vrai notamment des richesses du
sous-sol on peut pas le nier et
néanmoins et bien un des une un des
fléaux de ce continent c'est aussi que
les Africains quittent l'Afrique
et souvent contrairement à ce que les
gens croient c'est pas les plus miséreux
ce c'est les classes moyennes c'est les
plus éduqués vous confirmez ça oui
absolument il y a ce mouvement qui est à
la fois un signe d'ouverture du
continent vers l'extérieur de sa
mondialisation en réalité mais qui en
effet contribue à une fuite des cerveaux
que l'on constate alors en Europe on est
familier de ce phénomène puisque c'est
identifié au problème migratoires mais
d'autres régions du monde le voient
différemment il y a un nombre
impressionnant d'Africains qui ont gagné
les Amériques qu'il s'agisse du Canada
qu'il s'agisse des États-Unis et qui ont
plutôt réussi qui ont constitué des
diasporas assez conséquentes mais
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
nuit au développement local de ses
élites cela dit un grand nombre d'entre
elles choisissent aussi souvent d'y
revenir après même s'il y a une exil au
départ il y en a de plus en plus qui
choisissent aussi d'investir en Suisse
dans un certain nombre de domaines sur
le continent il y a aussi tous les
fléaux qui expliquent aussi la migration
c'est
le réchauffement climatique c'est
problème de santé d'alimentation c'est
une démographie qui est galopante et on
ne sait absolument pas si les pays sont
en mesure de pouvoir et bien assurer la
vie de toutes ces populations et un
manque de structure qui est phénoménal
oui et c'est là que l'on voit le rapport
avec l'extérieur par exemple en matière
de santé on le sait très peu ici mais le
principal partenaire en la matière c'est
l'Inde qui a développé sa relation avec
le continent autour de l'industrie du
médicament c'est quelque chose qui est
très intéressant aussi il y a beaucoup
d'Indiens
en Afrique de l'Est et l'Inde d'ailleurs
s'inscrit elle aussi aujourd'hui dans
cette dynamique en partie antioxydantal
en invoquant les liens de du Mahamad
Gandhi notamment avec l'Afrique puisque
était né en Afrique du Sud
exactement et donc de du rôle que
l'Afrique a joué dans ce combat
anti-impérialiste dans lequel l'Inde se
reconnaît également mais dans le domaine
de la santé il y a des acteurs
américains majeurs le rôle de la
Fondation Bill et Mélinda Gates est
absolument énorme sur le continent
africain donc on voit que bien sûr les
problèmes du continent l'handicap mais
crée aussi des opportunités d'échanges
avec les partenaires extérieurs y
compris privés alors le pape François
qui était il y a pas très longtemps en
République démocratique du Congo à
Kinshasa plus particulièrement où il a
été très très bien bien accueilli écrit
un discours assez fort en disant
ôtez vos mains de ce continent en
parlant à tous ceux qui veulent et bien
jouer les prédateurs et est-ce que
est-ce qu'il a encore une voix
importante en Afrique le pape dans un
dans un sur un continent où il y a deux
phénomènes religieux qui se produisent
il y a la montée de l'islamisme mais il
y a aussi la montée souvent de
l'Évangile évangélique absolument le
rôle des acteurs religieux sur le
continent africain est absolument majeur
on parle beaucoup en effet des acteurs
musulmans mais la façon dont les églises
évangélistes pullulent dans toutes les
régions du continent en Afrique
anglophone comme en Afrique francophone
comme en Afrique du Nord aussi du Nord
est absolument phénoménale en réalité et
c'est vrai que l'Église catholique
aujourd'hui porte quand même une voix
qui est entendue notamment en Afrique
centrale parce que elle s'est souvent
positionnée d'un point de vue politique
notamment oui tout à fait le rôle de la
Conférence des évêques en République
démocratique du Congo a été absolument
majeur pour s'élever notamment contre
les tentatives de Joseph Kabila
qui est l'ancien président
[Musique]
le rôle de l'Église catholique dans la
démocratisation a été absolument majeure
au Burkina Faso il a joué un rôle très
très important aussi mais c'est vrai que
il faut aujourd'hui compter avec ses
acteurs religieux qui sont de plus en
plus des acteurs politiques c'est
dangereux
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
l'idée d'un état totalement sécularisé
et quelque chose qui à mon avis recule
beaucoup sur le continent africain quel
que soit la foi auquel adhère le plus
grand nombre alors je disais que vous
aviez des origines de maliennes vous
êtes française vous êtes une métisse
le métissage en Afrique c'est quelque
chose qui est compliqué non
c'est quelque chose qui est partout
alors moi je l'ai jamais vécu comme
quelque chose de compliqué parce que bon
mon parcours fait que je ne me suis
jamais senti stigmatisé nulle part ni si
nous là-bas j'ai cette chance là parce
que il y a un homme qui a beaucoup parlé
du métissage mais c'est lui vous
connaissez t'étais pas métisse lui
d'ailleurs
il était autre chose lui parce qu'il
était catholique dans un pays à 80 ans
cette grande figure
l'étude donc moi je je ne l'ai jamais
vécu de manière négative mais ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'en Afrique
ni difficile ni difficile mais ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que en Afrique moi je
suis perçu comme quelqu'un de blonde
donc c'est quelque chose qui est et ici
comme quelqu'un de noir bien entendu la
difficulté moi je n'ai jamais vécu comme
une difficulté parce que je pense que
chacun a ses différences on peut être
gros on peut être
euh roux on peut être voilà avec une
jambe en moi et voilà et chacun arrive à
se construire dans cette différence
l'important c'est d'être dans un
environnement dans lequel on a la
possibilité
d'exister telle que l'on est et moi j'ai
toujours ressenti ça aussi bien en
France que sur le continent africain ce
métissage qui se voit sur votre peau
est-ce que c'est un métissage qui se
retrouve dans votre formation culturelle
en tout cas moi ce qui me paraît
extrêmement importante c'est d'être
capable d'avoir un amour pour son propre
pays donc qui est la France qui peut
être absolue ce qui est mon cas sans
être exclusif d'accord je pense que
l'exigence qui est faite aujourd'hui
d'un choix en matière
d'affirmation d'une identité et quelque
chose quand toute la journée
et qu'on peut totalement
de se sentir appartenir à la nation dans
laquelle on est né moi ma mère était
Corse alors ça ne se voit pas mais moi
le nom de famille ma mère était giacomy
elle était née à Corte donc c'est c'est
une part de mon identité qui est tout
aussi importante
voilà exactement c'est tout aussi
surprenant mais ce qui est extrêmement
important c'est que moi on m'a éduqué
dans le respect absolu de la France mais
tout en me parlant de mes autres
origines et je pense que le secret est
là aujourd'hui c'est de connaître ces
deux histoires merci niagaliba Kayoko
merci beaucoup
[Musique]